[Inaudible].
Uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, other than,
um, other
[inaudible] we all did.
[Inaudible] also
[inaudible] just come on the radio.
[Inaudible].
So think [inaudible] I'll stay there. Hi,
last year when I was several on day one
[inaudible] [inaudible] so [inaudible].
And do all that, the North pole.
So I hope I will do all that.
[inaudible] I think for them they help you fall shame some [inaudible], uh,
they are hard. Uh
[inaudible] uh
[inaudible] uh [inaudible].
I'm Nadia. I also handle
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, we are hopeless, our mom, their associates.
Um, no.
[Inaudible].
Also, uh, the, I also along the resume, um,
in learning man in the city about
[inaudible], uh, this is the
[inaudible] exam. That is
[inaudible] [inaudible] this is the year tonight. Epic.
[inaudible] so long now.
Um, also CLT and
[inaudible] uh, so Fatima had a helper.
[inaudible] her to this smeller. This is Sierra
with Dale Sierra. So Vita as much as dying,
no doubt. It held up that cost [inaudible]
again, or motor stair that I'd also,
uh [inaudible].
Would you up the chandeliers?
Uh, free? Uh, yeah, I remember we would have the tail [inaudible] bomb,
uh, hallmark [inaudible] [inaudible]
or [inaudible] reboot.
So medication Cinderella.
[Inaudible].
Yeah. Uh [inaudible] uh
[inaudible] uh, then, then Dogen
[inaudible] um,
and [inaudible] so relatively from about
[inaudible]. So you would have moved sort of there
[inaudible] the [inaudible] the mood sorta
[inaudible] that in some big wave surfers with the layer Hamilton associate,
I'm not going to not live my life afraid of what could happen or this is
[inaudible] yeah. I'm adult VCI.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so, w
also for the other, I couldn't go via the mother. Uh
[inaudible] or for them drought. What's called
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] yeah, [inaudible].
Near the [inaudible] just completed last [inaudible] Ned
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] that's
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].